keep Americans safe I'm going today by
doctor and sugar the principal deputy
director of the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention in Atlanta dr.
Tony Fauci of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Disease dr.
Robert Tablet HHS's assistant secretary
for preparedness and response and dr.
Steven Hahn the Commissioner of food and
drugs as of this morning we still have
only 14 cases of the china corona virus
detected here in the United States
involving travel to China or close
contacts with those travelers we have
three cases among Americans repatriated
from Wuhan and we have 40 cases among
American passengers are repatriated from
the diamond princess in Japan I want to
thank the responders and communities
that have worked with HHS and the
administration to provide these
Americans with the treatment they need
I'm also grateful to the governor's and
other state and local leaders who have
worked with us in close partnership so
far the immediate risk to the general
American public remains low but as we
have warmed that has the potential to
change quickly
there is now community transmission in a
number of countries including outside of
Asia that's deeply concerned and
community spread in other countries will
make successful containment at our
borders harder and harder that's why
we've all
been working closely with state local
and private sector partners to prepare
for mitigating the virus's potential
spread in the United States because we
will likely see more cases here as we
have said throughout this episode dr.
Shulkin
will provide some more details on what
that will look like including how we
would treat potential cases that arise
from community transmission here in the
United States this preparation has been
possible in part because of how
aggressively President Trump has
responded to this outbreak as soon as we
knew of the threat presented by this
novel virus public health leaders were
monitoring it and beginning to prepare
the travel restrictions that the
president put in place at the beginning
of this month have given our country
valuable time to continue to prepare and
that is precisely what those measures
were designed to do that includes
working with Congress yesterday the
White House sent our requests to
Congress to make at least two point five
billion dollars in funding available for
preparedness and response there are five
major priorities within the Supplemental
request which I underscored this morning
before the Senate Appropriations
Committee first we need to expand our
surveillance work building on an
existing system we have within CDC's
influenza surveillance network second we
will need funds to support Public Health
preparedness and response for state and
local governments for what could be a
very large-scale response we don't know
but we must prepare for that just in
case this support complements the
significant funds that these partners
have received from CDC for preparedness
about two-thirds of a billion dollars a
year in recent years third and fourth we
need to support the development of
therapeutics and the development of
vaccines given the scale of this
outbreak the private sector sees a real
market for both kinds of
countermeasures as well as for
Diagnostics but federal funding and
guidance can accelerate this work
dr. Falchi will address the current
status of that work in more depth fifth
and finally we need funds for the
purchase of personal protective
equipment for the strategic national
stockpile the topic that dr. Catlett can
address by noting that those scheduling
conflicts prevented this briefing from
including other members of the
president's coronavirus task force will
be providing a new update from
interagency leaders soon and we expect
to continue doing so regularly earlier
this afternoon on CNBC the National
Economic Council director Larry Kudlow
offered an update on how we see this
outbreak
affecting the economy this morning dr.
Matheny a from CDC provided the usual
telebriefing
as dr. Shugart will emphasize in just a
moment the Trump administration will
continue to be aggressively transparent
as the outbreak and our response evolve
will continue keeping the American
people and the media apprised of the
situation as well as what everyone can
do to prepare in the meantime I'll
continue to work closely with President
Trump and the president's Task Force on
our preparations to keep Americans safe
with that I'll hand things over a doctor
shook it for an update from the CDC
thanks so much I'd like to start out by
saying it's a difficult and uncertain
time we along with our partners around
the country and around the world have
been confronting a dynamic rapidly
evolving situation I'd like to let
Americans know that CDC and our nation's
public health agent
are preparing every day for this type of
situation preparedness started long
before this outbreak the US government's
response to the spread of a novel
coronavirus into our country began as
soon as reports of an unidentified
flu-like illness emerged from Wuhan
China the US has been implementing an
aggressive containment strategy that
requires detecting tracking and
isolating all cases as much as possible
and preventing more introductions of
disease notably at ports of entry we've
restricted travel into the US and have
issued multiple travel advisories for
countries currently experiencing
community spread our travel notices are
changing almost daily as we get new
information and we believe those
precautions are working so far as
secretaries are described our public
health system has detected 14 cases in
travelers or very close contacts of
travelers here in the United States
among passengers repatriated from by the
State Department from Wuhan China and
from the diamond princess there are an
additional three and forty cases the
fact that we have been able to keep
cases to this low level is an
accomplishment
especially given that we are
unfortunately beginning to see
communities spread in a growing number
of other countries based on what we know
right now we believe the immediate risk
here in the United States remains low
and we're working hard to keep that risk
low but we must use this time to
continue to prepare for the event of
community transmission
stays part of that preparation is
educating the public and our state local
and private sector partners about what
transition from aggressive containment
measures to community measures or
community mitigation would look like
should we end up there under our current
aggressive containment posture patients
infected with the corona virus who have
mild or no symptoms are being placed in
health care facilities for very close
observation and isolation that intensive
level of medical care is not typically
needed as we've watched these cases and
learned over the past several weeks we
realize that other approaches to
management are likely fine outside this
period of aggressive containment the
usual and appropriate care for most
patients who develop the novel
coronavirus or coded 19 would be
management at home through home
isolation with use of health care
facilities only as needed for those who
have severe presentations with the
elderly those with medical conditions
require a closer observation we will
maintain you for as long as practical a
dual approach where we continue these
measures of aggressive containment to
this disease but also employ strategies
to minimize the impact on our
communities however current global
circumstances suggest it's likely that
this virus will cause a pandemic in that
case risk assessment would be different
and new strategies tailored to local
circumstances would need to be
implemented to blunt the impact of the
disease and further slow the spread of
the virus what these interventions would
look like at the community level will
vary depending on
conditions and on the emerging
information about how severe the virus
may be now it's not so much a question
of if this will happen anymore but
rather more question of exactly when
this will happen and how many people in
this country will become infected and
how many of those will develop severe or
more more complicated disease we have
been preparing to address this type of
threat and limit the impact on our
communities for many years as some of
you heard from dr. Missoni a of the CDC
today we've begun laying out for the
public what it will look like to
mitigate the spread of the virus there
are obvious common-sense tools like good
hygiene social distancing things like
staying home when you're sick things we
talked about during a difficult flu
season or things that we talked about
during the 2009 h1n1 pandemic we will be
transparent with the public about these
measures and the potential that these
tools will be necessary there is
literally a playbook for the use of
these tools and one that the states and
local public health have exercised
we are committed at the CDC and across
HHS and the US government to radical
transparency to making sure we're
sharing what we know when we know it and
we're giving you a sense of what the
future may hold
I'd like to now turn things over to dr.
Falchi for his update thank you very
much and I'm gonna give a very brief
update on the countermeasure development
that I introduced to this audience on a
number of occasions over the past couple
of weeks and the first regarding the
issue of vaccine you might recall that I
had mentioned when we first introduced
the topic of vaccine that very shortly
after the sequence was put on a public
database we began a vaccine development
program which was one of several
supported both by the NIH as well as
water from aspirin and even independent
individuals that we have been involved
in collaborating with for a period of
time one of these vaccines I think
serves as the prototype of the timing of
what we were talking about you might
recall I had mentioned that from the
time we have available sequence we would
hope to be in clinical trials within two
to three months and I said barring any
glitches that would be the fastest in
any vaccine that we've gone from the
identification of a pathogen to putting
it into a human and in a phase one trial
well I'm happy to report to you this
afternoon that we are on time at least
and maybe even a little better the the
gene has been expressed in the platform
in this case a messenger RNA the
material has been produced it's been put
into mice as immunogenic and it's now
getting ready to go through the
regulatory issues of getting it to go so
I would project that we would be in a
human
I would say within a month and a half
and I had thought that maybe cut a week
or so off again hopefully no further
glitches now the thing we need to
understand because we want to make sure
people don't get confused that getting a
vaccine into a phase one trial within a
three-month period do you need at least
three to four months to determine if
it's safe and whether it induces the
kind of response that you would predict
would be protective once you do that you
graduate to a much larger trial the end
of the number of people in the phase 1
trial is 45 when you go a phase 2 trial
you're talking about hundreds if not
thousands of individuals to determine
efficacy there is a trial they would
have to conduct in those countries in
those areas with this active
transmission that itself even at rocket
speed would take at least an additional
six to eight months so when you're
talking about the availability of a
vaccine even to scale it up you're
talking about a year to a year and a
half now you shouldn't be discouraged by
that because it is certainly conceivable
that this issue with this corona virus
will go well beyond this season into
next season so a vaccine may not solve
the problems of the next couple of
months but it certainly would be an
important tool that we would have and
we'll keep you posted on that secondly
and finally the issue but there are
pubic interventions there are a number
of candidates that we are now looking at
that I've shown some suggestion either
in vitro in an animal model or some
period trials that we're done during the
Mayoress outbreak one of these and there
are several that we're considering is
called room desapear which is a
nucleotide analog that is produced by
Gilead today as I speak there are two
major clinical trials going on in China
which are randomized controlled trials
which means that we will get an
yes sir whether or not it works what
doesn't work I think within a reasonable
period of time an identical copy of that
trial is now being implemented in
Nebraska with our colleagues who are
taking care of the individuals who had
taken from the Diamond Princess and
thought back here in addition to our
colleagues in Japan so I'm optimistic
that we will at least get an answer if
we do have a therapy that really is a
game changer because then we could do
something from the standpoint of
intervention for those who are sick so
hopefully I'll get the opportunity in
the future to continue to update on
these interventions thank you I'd like
to introduce top academy dr. Feld you
thank you very much and good afternoon
everyone
Esper is providing an unprecedented
operational and logistical support to
the State Department to repatriate
approximately 1,100 Americans from China
from the diamond Princess cruise ship in
Japan we are pleased that the passengers
evacuated from China have completed
their 14-day quarantine quarantine and
have returned to their homes and
families safely passengers evacuated
from the diamond princess from the
process of completing their 14-day
quarantine and to DoD installations one
in California and one in Texas medical
professionals from our National Disaster
medical system and CDC are continually
monitoring the health of these
passengers and passengers as show signs
of any illness of them thought the DoD
facility and tested for this virus that
passengers were tested positive for this
current virus cannot stay on the
military installations and these
patients are being transported safely to
our network of special pathogen
treatment centers such as the University
of Nebraska Medical Center as part of
our aggressive containment posture these
individuals are being placed in these
facilities for quarantine and isolation
purposes only
an intensive level of medical care is
not typically needed by most of these
individuals at these centers
the patients that have developed this
infection can participate in the
clinical trial the doctor felt he
described with room.this we are honored
to have helped NIH to arrange their
clinical trial within this special
network of treatment centers in addition
our biomedical Advanced Research
Development Authority Barda is working
with Regina Ron to develop two possible
treatments and with Janssen and Johnson
& Johnson to screen existing and
investigation and treatments and
compounds to identify any that have
potential use in Trudy coronavirus and
with Janssen and Santa Fe to develop
vaccines using vaccine technology that
the United just supported for pandemic
influenza vaccines we're reviewing
hundreds of proposals for additional
therapeutics and vaccines and a
particular Diagnostics that can be used
in hospital and clinical labs or doctors
offices we're also prepared to support
CDC and topography homeland security of
designated military installations we're
Americans returning to the US on
commercial flights can be pauran team
based on their travel history the most
recent location to receive such a
traveller is a naval base in Ventura
County for Point Mugu where one American
is currently completing quarantine any
quarantine in any of these military
installations would not have any
symptoms or positive test result
quarantine is based solely on their
travel history that places them at high
risk for possible exposure their health
is continually monitored and they're
transferred safely to medical facilities
for testing and treatment if any
symptoms develop it is not my pleasure
to introduce dr. Stephen Hahn from the
FDA
thank you dr. Calvin and thank you for
the opportunity to update you today on
FDA's current elías activities the FDA
plays an essential role in overseeing
our nation's medical products as part of
our vital mission to protect and promote
public health including during public
health emergencies the FDA is an active
partner in the novel Crona
virus response working closely with our
government and public health partners
across the US Department of Health and
Human Services as well as our
international counterparts our work is
multifaceted focusing on actively
facilitating efforts to diagnose treat
and prevent the disease surveilling the
medical product supply chain for
potential shortages or disruptions and
helping to mitigate such impacts as
necessary and leveraging the full
breadth of our public health tools as we
oversee the safety and quality of FDA
regulated products for American patients
and consumers I'm happy to answer
questions about FDA's activities but
I'll provide a few updates first of all
the supply chain empty is keenly aware
that the outbreak will likely affect the
medical product supply chain including
potential disruptions to supply of
shortages of critical medical products
in the u.s. we are proactively reaching
out to hundreds of medical product
manufacturers to gather information
about the supply chain first it's
important to note that FDA is not aware
not aware of any medical products
shortages at this time we are however
monitoring several products that might
be at risk particularly personal
protective equipment but we do not have
any manufacturer shortages to report
please be assured if a potential
shortage or disruption of medical
products is identified by the FDA we
will use all of our available tools to
react swiftly and mitigate the impact to
us patients and health care
professionals and we will take steps to
quickly share that information with the
public with respect to inspections for
February and March FDA is identified
approximately 100 scheduled inspections
in China the vast majority of which are
certain routine surveillance inspections
those inspections are just postponed at
this time and will be conducted at a
later date it's important to remember
that
delay routine surveillance inspections
can happen at any time during year and
while inspections in China delayed
secondary to the State Department travel
advisory we will send investigators to
other parts of the world to ensure we
are on schedule for our planned
inspections for the year also we'd like
to remind everyone that the inspections
are just one tool that FDA can use to
monitor compliance and to help prevent
products that do not need FDA standards
for entering the u.s. marketplace this
process has a number of layers in place
and is not solely reliant on boots on
the ground inspections overall this
remains an evolving and very dynamic
issue that we will vigilantly monitor we
are committed to continuing to
communicate with the public as we have
further updates thank you thank you dr.
hall at this point why don't we open up
for questions yes if you just wait for
the microphone so the TV cameras can
hear your question um Thank You
secretary burns I am Oliver John with
China's Tai Chi media the first
questions as China's Colonel MERS cases
seems to be contained
well there are other countries like
Italy Japan or South Korea seems
expanding and what are you considering
loosen the risk travel restrictions
regarding foreigners with travel history
from China well considering imposing
travel restrictions with you no travel
history is regarding the above three
countries and also I noticed that you
were still referring the cohere 19 as
China coronavirus well I think people I
think that were to change this took away
at 19 because they think the China
criminalize my
like that a phobia or racism do you
think it's proper to still like refer it
to China corner of our things so we
intend to keep our travel restrictions
with regard to China in place at the
moment the the virus is still spreading
in China we're still having countries of
case reports per day if that's capturing
all the information we're still seeing
dozens or more fatalities reported per
day we certainly hope that China is able
to engage in effective containment
measures to slow the spread of this
virus down but there's nothing at this
point that would indicate a change in
our posture towards our aggressive
containment measures with regard to
travel in China it's important though to
remember we've been very moderated and
titrated in those travel measures they
simply are based on 14 days which is the
maximum predicted incubation period and
so an individual who has been in China
for the previous 14 days who is a
foreign national would not be permitted
to enter the United States and an
American or permanent resident would be
permitted to return to the United States
of course but asked to home isolate
during the completion of a 14-day period
outside of China that is not a ban that
is a temporary restriction in line with
the public health measures that we're
taking so we've tried to be very
respectful towards in towards of travel
and of course those restrictions are not
based on other than American and
permanent resident versus non Americans
really as a matter of focusing our
resources they're not based on the
ethnicity of an individual or anything
else because as you mentioned it is
important that we not engage in any -
that people not believe that because of
somebody's ethnicity they are more
likely to have this disease or not our
criteria are all based on travel and
affected areas and warning people that
travel infected areas that based on
based on the epidemiology and the
evidence
Briona did you have yes so thank you
it's a good day it's alright so the
cdc's of this morning that Americans
should prepare for their everyday lives
to potentially be disrupted disrupted by
the inevitable spread of the current
virus in the US your your comments
haven't gone quite as far and the
president also tweeted that everything
is under control
can you address the difference in
messaging and then secondly given what
you know now are you expecting community
spread in the US and near future and how
confident are you that the u.s. is
prepared to respond
let me ask dr. Shulkin if you speak to
the CDC's discussion this morning yeah
thank you I think dr. Missoni talked
about the potential for community
transmission and helping Americans think
about what that would mean I need to
help Americans frame what to expect it's
helpful to think about a bad flu year or
even the 2009 pandemic we're in
different locations at different times
the circumstances are part of different
measures the idea of exactly what that
will look like in the United States is
hard to say and of course the images
we've been seeing from from China for
who they profits are are quite different
from what we would expect in the u.s.
context so I think what's really
important for people is to be stay
informed stay aware and to learn about
the circumstances we really think every
everyday measures like covering your
cough or sneeze staying home when you're
sick are very important and of course
the Evergreen wash your hands we do know
that at the beginning of the h1n1
pandemic schools were closed that's one
of those social
community mitigation tools well schools
were closed briefly until we learned
more about the virus and what to expect
and we realized that the the trade-off
between the disruption of school
closures and the benefit of school
closures for that particular virus the
the equation suggest that we didn't need
to do that and instead we moved to a
message of children staying home when
they were sick so I think dr. Messenians
comments were really to frame what might
happen in the future it's very important
to say that our efforts of containment
so far have worked and the virus is
actually contained here in the United
States we don't want to delay thinking
about other possibilities and it was
really an educational moment that that
she talked about yes yeah hi this is
Donna with AFP just on the transmission
and Status movement primarily
respiratory but is there any more
confirmed information about the
possibility there have been a few
isolated papers on asymptomatic and the
fecal-oral route and for
for the FDA the question was a what sort
of it's a personal protective equipment
are we talking about face masks and that
sort of thing great
let me ask talk about you perhaps and
then duck or not so anecdotally it's
clear that there are people who would
judge to be asymptomatic when questioned
who very likely transmitted infection
during the period of time that they were
in the asymptomatic State the question
is is that a predominant modality of
transmission what we call a driver of an
outbreak or is it one that's minor from
talking to people who over there now but
getting more and more information as
papers come in to look at to review it
looks like a it does occur but B it is
not something that is the predominant
way that it's transmitted now obviously
you need to be aware of that and issues
of testing and things like that but I
think but getting closer to a better
understanding of that in terms of PD or
personal protective equipment we're
talking masks respirators gowns and
there's no question that there's
pressure on the demand side here so
we're keeping a very close eye on this
and a forward-leaning approach because
we may in fact to see some effect on the
supply chain there yes
so if you tato with ABC News earlier
today members of Congress had a lot of
questions about whether or not the
emergency supplemental request would be
enough and I guess can you kind of offer
some insight in how do you guys came to
that number and why you feel like that
well suffice
sure so so the supplemental request
would offer us 2.5 billion dollars of
spending first it's important that's
money to be spent in 2020 so that's
between now and September 30th of this
year we would have a provision
authorizing carryover spending to 2021
fiscal year if needed but it really is
this year's spending and we told the
appropriators is we're in the middle of
looking at the next year's appropriation
and so let's work together on that on
top of in addition to any additional
needs and we'll have a lot more learning
we're learning every day and every week
more about this virus and the disease
progression and that will help inform
those longer-term discussions about 2021
now isn't the 2.5 billion dollars they
said five key areas first we've got to
expand our surveillance system to be
more comparable to what our flu
surveillance system is like we need to
get we want to test people with flu-like
symptoms or any potential symptoms that
would resonate with the corona virus so
we can ensure that we have rapid
detection if anybody's getting this so
that's part of the scale out there the
second is are staying local partners of
the frontlines of any kind of Public
Health response we fund about half of
state and local public health already
and 675 million a year of emergency
response but we know there will be
additional needs with lab testing
contact tracing etc the vaccine develop
R&D dr. felt you talked to you about
that we want to put multiple bets on the
table we have a billion dollars in there
for vaccine development we will have
multiple bets on the table we want to
speed that along as quickly as possible
now we can assess whether there's a need
for us to make in the market in terms of
purchasing frankly this is such global
attention right now and the
market plans major pharmaceutical
players as you've heard are engaged in
this that we think that this is not like
our normal kind of bioterrorism
procurement processes where the
government might be unique purchaser say
of a smallpox therapy the market here we
believe will actually sort that out in
terms of demand purchasing stocking etc
work on that to make sure that we're
able to accelerate vaccine as well as
therapeutic research and development
multiple bets upon therapeutics also as
dr. felt you referred to and then dr.
Catholic will lead our efforts in
addition on personal protective
equipment procurement for instance
scaling up acquisition n95 face masks
which would be primarily used for
healthcare providers to protect them in
multiple interactions in the community
our advice remains as it has been that
the average American does not need to
need a n95 mask these are really more
for health care providers and also gowns
for used in hospital settings gloves etc
for that it's that type of equipment
that we would add to our existing mr.
Carlos saying it's tightly contained he
was Senator Graham saying it seems to be
getting worse not better
and the CDC saying that Americans need
to prepare because this might get back
which is it and what exactly do they
need to do to prepare so I'm gonna ask
doctor shook it to talk about some of
the advice but let me start by saying
we're trying to engage in radical
transparency with the American public as
we go as we go through this each of
those messages is accurate but addresses
a particular aspect of what we're
talking about so for instance abroad
this is spreading quite rapidly in the
United States thanks to the President
and this team's aggressive containment
efforts this disease as dr. shook it
is contained we are now two weeks with
no additional US base cases 14 cases On
February 11th 14 cases today that is
remarkable level of containment here in
the United States the only additional
cases we have are ones we imported
that's part of our humanitarian
repatriation efforts then we tried to be
very transparent with the American
public we have from day one so we can't
hermetically seal off the United States
I stood here at this podium I stood at
the White House press briefing will
really announced our initial initial
travel restrictions and we've always
said we expect to see more cases we that
should we don't want people surprised if
they see more cases here in the United
States that's an important part of
transparency people shouldn't panic when
they see new cases they should know
their government predicted we would have
them and we have plans in place and then
that gets to what dr. Meza DA's table
was talking about this morning which was
just previewing for the American people
that as we see additional cases we
actually have tools we may not yet have
a vaccine or a therapeutic we have
Public Health tools of mitigation that
we can and will use and it's important
for people to know we aren't helpless we
have tools we have as dr. Shugart said
we have actually defined a playbook for
taking steps to help if we do see
community spread how broad any type of
community spread we do not know it is
very dangerous to make predictions with
a virus especially a novel virus but we
have tools to deal with it that are
reasonable titrated and don't
excessively interfere either with the
economy or individuals lives necessarily
so all of this is it's part of the same
message which is this is a very serious
public health condition worldwide we are
taking this incredibly serious here in
the United States we are doing the most
aggressive containment efforts in modern
history to prevent further spread in the
United States we're going to continue
taking those measures but we are
realistic then we will see more cases
and as we see more cases
we might have to take community
mitigation efforts what will those look
like we're being transparent about those
also so it's all to make sure that the
American public go on this journey
educating with us we're keeping people
fully informed of what will happen
almost so that people can predict what
we would do and what we would say in
advance because we have been so
transparent about what our PlayBook is
and how we think about these issues I
can't account for people on the hill and
what they say doctor to discuss what dr.
Messier was speaking about which again
is about transparency about potential
actions or measures in the future part
of preparedness is in an educated
population thinking about the future we
hope those steps are necessary we hope
that we don't face those kind of
eventualities
but transparency is being candid with
people about what the continued of a
potential steps are so that they can
start processing in their own heads
thinking about in their own lives what
that might involve might might involve
not will we cannot make predictions with
any degree of certainty about how a
virus was proto what will happen what we
can say now is that thanks to our
aggressive containment efforts we have
contained the spread of this into the
United States fourteen cases now for two
weeks solid and we're gonna keep working
to contain the spread of this but if we
need to we'll take appropriate public
health measures to help mitigate that
but I forget yeah and just to kind of
elaborate on the
steps when we think about communities
measures not just the aggressive
containment you know in each individual
case what we do and around all their
context we think about the individual or
personal steps at mitigating spread
things like staying home when you're
sick we think about the community steps
things like a different approach to
gatherings you know perhaps if you're
elderly with underlying conditions you
might not go to that big concert and
others could we also think about
environmental measures things like
cleaning commonly touch surfaces a
little bit more than you might otherwise
big focuses the healthcare system and
really using it appropriately and not
overusing it or under using it and
helping people helping the health care
system be prepared but also helping
consumers patients know what to expect
when they want to seek care when to call
a nurse line instead of going to the
doctor's yourself so I think this
PlayBook that dr. Missoni laid now is
really foreshadowing the kinds of things
that we may need to do of course we've
been watching the situation in China
closely and then of course the recent
emergence of communities spread in Italy
and Iran and in South Korea have raised
questions with people of what might
happen here we want people to be ready
in terms of if we do see communities
spread what would that mean to you maybe
something different in your community
than another community depend on local
circumstances but we wanted people to
look at what that road map might be we
do think that we've done mitigation
before we've learned from the past in
terms of what was appropriate what
perhaps was overkill and we want to
educate folks about what we've learned
and what they can expect
when she said get prepared what that
means if you're you know if you're a
parent first if you're my my parents in
their 70s first in terms of a young
child birth mean what I would say is CDC
gov there are checklists there for
businesses for employers for schools for
consumers for travelers we've already
been educating the public about travel
here are some places to watch there's an
outbreak but it's contained here's some
places where we suggest no travel you
know do not travel unless it's
absolutely essential so I think that the
circumstances are changing and staying
informed is the best thing that people
can do that's that's really what I would
advise see what you're getting about
when you ask the question what you
should do but dr. Mason Yang was saying
nothing that you can do right now but if
it comes to the point where we're gonna
have to respond with mitigation these
are the kind of things you might be
thinking about you I have to do she
wasn't telling you anything that you
needed to do now so you need to do
nothing different than you're already
doing but she wanted in the in the in
the realm of transparency to let the
American public know if we need to
mitigate these are the kind of things
you might want to think of and that's
why I think there's no incompatibility
with what we're saying here and what she
said thanks and I find cursory yes thank
you hi I'm Tina darling in Burgas thank
you I wanted to ask about the influence
of surveillance system and the use of it
and if you're seeing an increase in
flu-like or pneumonia symptoms that end
up testing negative that could
potentially indicate that the corona
virus might be circulating and and then
separately when do you think the
Sentinel system for the corona virus
might be up and running yeah thank you
those questions are influenza
surveillance uses a number of different
approaches and every week we update that
data at cdc.gov and flu you what we're
doing is adding a test for a virus to
individuals who are presenting with
influenza like illness we're still in
the midst of influenza season and a very
high proportion of those specimens are
showing influenza of one type or another
but as we add the the corona virus we
hope to detect before it gets widespread
the occurrence of this if it is out
there in the community we're already
beginning this effort and five sites and
that'll be kind of rolling out over the
next couple of weeks and learning from
that how to expand it throughout the
nation so essentially it's adding the
PCR or polymerase chain reaction test
for corona virus to the other testing
for influenza that the public health
apps are already doing in this influenza
surveillance system thank you one last
pop-up in the back
and I'm Carol Pearson I'm with The Voice
of America just for a reality check I
would like to see the comparison between
the lethality and transmissibility of
this novel coronavirus with influenza
the current string that's going around
and I would like to also find out if the
Ebola outbreak in West Africa between
2014 and 2016 the CDC help the Liberian
government run PSAs about how to protect
yourself from getting this given the
fact that an MIT study just showed that
only 6 to 7 percent of people to wash
their hands properly meaning 15 seconds
with soap and water there are there any
plans for that thank you dr. Patrick
perhaps can you talk about ability or
another County a standard flu season
seasonal flu the lethality is 0.1% right
now depending upon what the denominator
is the lethality for the current
coronavirus infection is somewhere
around 2% you know if you do different
studies that are coming out 2.5 2.6 1.9
about 2 percent if you compare it to the
SARS outbreak it was 9 to 10 percent
Maris was 36 percent and then if you go
through the history of pandemic
influenza depending upon the year it
anywhere from point 5.6% when you get to
the 1918 is 1.5 to 2 percent yeah and in
terms of the consumer education and in
hand-washing we are always trying to
promote hand-washing and you know
that's a core message for for child
Care's kids and for the American public
during influenza season and I would
expect to see more of the types of
approaches to promoting hand-washing
perhaps trying to integrate a little bit
more of the innovative approaches and
not the old sort of PSA approach great
thank you thank you all very much and
we're going to keep trying to do these
briefings I want to make sure they're as
regular as possible so that you media
that access to us to get your questions
answered of course we have our regular
CDC morning briefings approximately two
to three times per week as well as other
events where we've got home I think
every single day senior leaders out in
the media but we're going to keep doing
that to make sure we're very available
and getting you information and
assessments as we have them so thank you
very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
but before we rush to nominate senator
Sanders in our one shot to take on this
president let us take a sober look at
what is at stake for our party
for our values and for those with the
most to lose
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're a community that lived through
SARS and so we understand that hopefully
this will be a temporary abandonment of
Chinatown that people will eventually
start coming back to Chinatown I often
say with New Yorkers you know their
tolerance to be without Chinese food is
only so long eventually people are going
to need their Chinese food so we're
we're hoping that people still
understand that there are no cases of
coronavirus and that